[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
we're only going to break down every hit
classic song from disturb welcome back
to the break room our daily show that
keeps you updated on nerdy news you need
to know uh i'm jessica clemens but
coming up we have some han solo joining
the mcu
[Laughter]
good lord barbie's ken is getting lit on
fire bringing back bbw
baby and we're not talking about a
barbecue 2022 emmy nominations have been
announced and who got who got the nods
and who will have to settle which is
having superhero bots
they all have superhero bods it's really
uh truly they do i do not
but you know who does
brandon barrack no
i am mid-herobot you're built like thor
i say that every day i come into this
office you said that i've never heard
you say that before
such a warm welcome every time i feel so
loved
thank you thank you
it's the aggressor
homesick looking like a celtic yeah i'm
mailed to him
boston yeah
oh
today's redemption is still thor themed
for every hundred dollars we will be
swearing but in honor of the guy who
puts the ass and asgardian thor we will
be using the jar of ancient viking curse
words also this week we are introducing
two week long stretch goals first if we
hit 1 000 tommy bechtold will get any
haircut that we choose yeah live on the
show friday tommy will get a haircut if
wow a thousand dollars over the week
that's that that's gonna happen and also
who said that we are eligible to cut
hair you guys
that's part of the fun yeah that's part
of the fun is we if we do the bull cut
i'm putting the ball on top and going
across right he's got a lot of hair to
work with getting the wheel buyers
decide what he's doing yeah and we'll be
using a manscaped razor
that episode has to be sponsored a
little extra maybe yes if we cross two
thousand dollars total this week uh the
break room will go
gentle minions challenge this weekend
and by us mainly zach zach will go i am
telling him exactly i am not being
forced into this again i'm not going
jessica will put on a suit i'll put on a
suit zach will put on this last time
zach before it was like we're all going
to see morbius for the third time and
then we
everyone bailed except for me
it was morbid time just for you he
got a white shirt wrote more than time
on it
that's just you
it was just amazing and i was like zach
why am i here
god it was horrible but let's get into
this let's start yeah yeah let's kick it
off with some headlines
did the graphic play i can't see it it
hasn't oh okay there it is it's
beautiful
first
is it is it morbid shirt
yeah it's always good by zach we're
selling that for ten thousand dollars
right away hey here's our first headline
beating feldstein out and funny girl
what uh just kidding what a crazy story
that is uh josh horowitz from mtv news
spoke with the spoke with ryan geisling
about a potential role in the mcu and
addressed the nova rumors floating
around the internet people thinking it
might be a nova horowitz said quote ryan
and i chatted what a flex uh about the
nova rumors yesterday which he said
aren't true but this morning ryan
reached out to me to say there is one
superhero he wants to play and that
superhero is
ghostwriter
well nicholas there no niggles will say
over my dick also do you think ryan like
texted him like in the morning like hey
hey i just wanted i just i i realized i
forgot to mention i'm a big johnny blade
woke him up and he's like hey uh i don't
know if i said this but i would be ghost
right now yeah i like to think of them
like in the drive jacket but he's like
silent all night he's like
he's just like
he showed him the the bank robbing
footage from place beyond the pines was
like i can ride a motorcycle let me do
it look at me i'm go trainer
to be honest between the penance there
and the fact that the character is so
interesting in mythology and like the
things that ryan gosling seems to be
drawn to are roles where he can be very
expressive in like silence like there's
a lot of like that undercurrent that i
think would work like i see why he's
drawn to it i mean you gotta pay for
gosling and have a fire skull the whole
time yeah yeah you gotta get on the bike
chips get a body here on him as nova or
ghost rider
i think he's great as ken and that's
where he's gonna stay in the bbw i'd
like him as cyclops they go older with
the uh the cast he's my cyclops oh okay
okay all right well we'll have to see
next headline deadline is reporting that
alden ehrenreich has been cast in the
upcoming disney plus iron heart series
there are no details on who he will be
playing uh this was of course young han
solo you all loved him so much in that
role you loved the film you saw it so
many times in theaters uh and
it did so well it did so well it killed
the star wars movie spin off friends
make kenobi into a series instead of a
movie uh but yeah he's coming ironheart
is he gonna be related to justin hammer
that's all i care about i would kill for
that i want hammer back more than most
things i want his dyed hands i want his
sunscreen hands but i do think like
alden wasn't the problem with that movie
and i think a lot of people have
realized that like i i don't think that
movie is as plot as some people do but i
also don't think he's any of the problem
so i'm glad that disney's like hey
here's a big show let's get you back on
top got to be like a lot of pressure to
come back in i mean even oscar isaacs
have talked about like coming into
moonlight he was like i don't even want
to go through this again yeah you know
having been like apocalypse and then
going through star wars and dealing with
like all the pressure of like alden such
a good actor though like he's like hail
caesar uh the full disclosure he and i
did speed the plow together we did david
play together me and alden and the dude
shameless name dropped for the guy and i
don't know your monologue
but but he's able to do so much with
like kind of like gosling he's able to
be really contained and then just like
have emotion and i feel like you want
someone that's
that capable of being immediately
endearing like when you have a cast like
iron heart where you're introducing a
new hero when you're doing a tech that
you're used to when you're bringing in a
whole new world you've got to have
characters immediately work so an actor
like alden who you feel something for
right away it's really smart
zach joked about alan slack today but
could he be yet another version of
howard stark somehow like a middleweight
like he's not like a younger howard
stark not slattery but also like
yeah a younger howard stark than agent
carter but not quite that old yet yeah
no into it i'm sorry i'm looking at the
chat where they're like i love solo and
i am
one with the chat i actually remember
watching someone like i love this movie
it's coming back around the reviews i
was like
why do they hate it hey next headline in
a phone call with insider taikawatiti
revealed that guardians of the galaxy
were originally going to come back at
the end of the film uh but he ultimately
shelved the idea here's his quote the
thing is that happens in every movie no
more no more of the cavalry coming in at
the end so we just shelved the idea we
just wanted jane to come in at the end
so it sounds like there was maybe this
idea that the guardians show back up
again much like han solo in the trench
run to help at the very end and be like
we're here we're gonna shoot gore for
you but they scrapped it would you have
wanted to see the guardians again at the
end of thor eleven thunder or were you
fine just i was fine with the beginning
yeah i liked how they wrapped it up with
shannon coming through yeah that was
adequate
does feel sort of finally talk about it
after like two weeks of doing the show
about it yeah i do think that a lot of
people assume there'd be like kind of
the bookend thing because the guardians
of the galaxy were set up i do feel like
it was one of those things where taika
was just handed like here's the story
you've got to do and they're like
guardians are here and i do kind of feel
like they were pushed out and i would
have liked to see more of them but maybe
not here like i'm really excited for the
holiday special in guardians 3. yeah i
would love that there's a little thorin
guardians 3 like we kind of see the
other side of it at the very beginning
and then and a little roshaman action
see where it splits off there i got like
a little flashback of him on the ship
just hanging over some more goats yeah
yeah more of the ghost or the screaming
goats
in this interview also revealed that uh
there was a sea witch of goldblum and of
course it got left on the cutting room
floor he's not in it here was this quote
he said a scene on its own could be the
most funniest thing or intriguing thing
but sometimes those things if you keep
them in will just make the movie screech
to a halt so you have to do what's best
for the film so they cut it he says it's
a pacing issue maybe i don't know
they've cut so much from this film that
we've we've learned about
my biggest question is like
was maybe
the grandmaster going to be killed and
then
so he wasn't killed so this is like big
cannon implications right right there
was a version there's a timeline where
he dies and we know he's dead because we
don't know if the collector's dead
either right he's like maybe dead
and the grandmaster is like a big
a big g god like
i feel like with all the phase four
implications of where we're going with
gods and afterlives and all the things
we're building to we're gonna need
characters we're familiar with that are
like og you know like these big power
sets op and og you want them to be
already established that way when you
introduce the celestials in a like a
broader sense i think a lot of the
reason that people didn't like eternals
was it threw a lot at you at once so
maybe you keep some you know that way
when you get to see your wars inevitably
you've got some familiarity yeah
hopefully yeah i will say uh uh next
headline stranger things 4 got nominated
for 13 emmys today including best drama
series way to go guys uh the show failed
to score a single acting nomination yeah
you did you did fine uh who got snubbed
in the stranger's things captain sadie i
think sadie said
sure
and eddie like he was such a great debut
we were so immediately and dear to that
dude any person that had to cry not the
will cry that was away from the car
not that one that one didn't count those
two though had really good like i'm
about to die and this is my last moment
here's how i'm gonna
convey it lucas in the penultimate
episode there like lucas's work and then
the like the finale where he's dealing
with all of that like i think i can't
get over lucas uh
lewis at all
i love lucas and then i'm just always
like wow they should have put more erica
in this uh i'm obsessed with his little
sister oh eric is great erica is so
perfect and i was so happy when she took
his turn uh playing d d i was like oh
keep her in yeah yeah she's a child
i mean do you think maybe they're
waiting for the final season and then
they'll throw some like nominations out
to be kind
uh they like to do that sometimes
yeah when his shows run for a while like
they'll throw out some stuff at the end
as someone that cannot vote for the
emmys but
works for a show that is constantly
winning emmys um they don't get that
much time and there was not enough time
from because it's also like you're like
yeah so you're like oh here's part one i
already watched that uh but there's this
other show that i already watched that i
i know fully through and then by the
time they already submitted their votes
it's like oh here's the second part and
the second part's like a massive i think
difference and i think that's what the
winning factor would have been so i
don't think they had enough time
especially at lucas like the second half
is when they like they built up quietly
where he was going and all of a sudden
it's like this is the power moment the
second half just came out take away
second half after the nomination
deadline
it might have been it might have taken
up i don't know hey if you work for the
emmys please
throw it in there so midnight mass got
completely snubbed like that mask was
such a good show yeah there's only so
many enemies thinking about there's so
many tv shows what are we gonna do we
gotta keep giving it to the hbo show
lotus flower
is coming in strong lotus yeah euphoria
these teenagers hey
the mcu's disney plus series also got
nominated for a host of emmys including
uh what if god nomination for best
animated program as well as voice
performance nominations for both
chadwick boseman and jeffrey wright uh
hawkeye nominated for outstanding stunt
performance some good stunts in there uh
loki nabbing sevignon seven noms
including how sandy production design
for a narrative period of fantasy
program what a title uh and moon knight
scoring eight nominations including
outstanding character voice over
performance for f murray abraham and a
sound editing and stunt nomination and
uh i'm so happy that moon knight swept
that for the for marvel i'm so happy
even though loki did get a lot i'm like
i'm so happy moon and i got eight yeah
they just need to get one more i needed
i needed moon knight to get one more i
was like no acting nominations the only
acting nominations any marvel show has
gotten was elizabeth olsen yeah for one
this is a show that went to the 50s like
that's that's how the voting works uh we
asked you guys in the chat would you
rather see ryan gosling as nova or ghost
writer and you guys want nova all right
interesting uh and would you like to
have seen more guardians of the galaxy
in door four it was close 51 said yes so
real real flip of the coin before y'all
there they're getting the whole movie
they're getting a whole other movie and
a christmas special and a christmas
special and a diamond root show and i
have a girl get some guardians that's
its own canon yeah it's the whole thing
as he said ryan gosling for cyclops i'm
just saying ever a welterweight of
quotes and interviews marvel exec richie
palmer showed up at empire's spoiler
special podcast and said the mcu phase 4
is all about fallout from avengers end
game now i tweeted out my rankings of
all the phase four films so far and got
a fair amount of guff from people in
this very room so i want you guys to
give me your rankings i want to see if
we agree or disagree let's bring out the
board we got it we got the whiteboard
set up i even made tick-tock videos i
ranked them all in like length
explaining them all i did a lot of
explaining this journey we're about to
go on so come at me chat i got reasons
please don't get up
you got it you got it honey also later
on the real reason this week i did all
37 marvel properties ranked friends
while this chaos is sorry uh brandon
doesn't have a filter to stop screaming
okay
now we're gonna talk about where i think
phase four is heading after we rank
these so quick
put your movies in order of facebook so
we all do or should you go first and
then i'll do it simultaneously all right
everybody let's do it like maniacs you
gotta think really hard about it
i mean
it's just forever
[Applause]
oh i feel bad
don't feel bad i have no room
and some recency bias might be a thing
but i feel i feel like this is this is
my world okay all right all right
yes you do see that yellow one right
there
yes i see you're zooming in i'm
understanding the disparity okay do you
want to break break down like your
thoughts yeah real real quick we don't
have to make an essay about it okay uh
easy but it's not fair they had so 20
years to work to build that [ __ ]
right john uh this was great get over it
folks get over it shang chi what a
breath of fresh air uh love the fight
scene so great had a lot of fun with
thor love and thunder black widow was
good i
it was good at the end
okay spider-man no way home was able to
accomplish 20 years of summary of an
experience making my favorite character
in the history of comics the character
i've always dreamed of being while also
giving a brand new origin it established
spider-man the cinematic universe's
canon in a brand new way and gave us
uncle ben's by way of spider-man
multiverse enhancing both the
spider-verse story the sinister six
story and the spider-man cinematic story
eternals i think we're gonna look back
in five years as one of the great
accomplishments of the mcu it's able to
introduce 12 characters and have you so
invested in their characterization you
actually understand their thoughts and
processes even when they're not off
screen so actions are taking place
during this film their people are not
even there and you understand their
justification for those actions and it
basically establishes humans as cannon
fodder and makes the eternals both
heroes and villain what they do is
sacrifices billions of lives to save us
that's an ultimate hero move also a very
strong villainous choice and the
villains in this film are effectively
human they're sentient they're
self-aware they're able to do things
this is a very beautifully conflicting
movie about what it means to have power
because it was bad okay
she
is i think one of the best solo marvel
films to date it's able to build out its
world it's able to establish a very
charming lead it's able to establish a
very charming world beyond the mcu while
still touching on the mcu one of the
best expansions of the mcu to date thor
love and thunder is a lot of fun it's
definitely a little uneven for me the
first half is a little too strongly
comedy for the subject matter the second
half finds its tone finds its balance
it's my favorite last five minutes of
maybe any ncu film and where it lands
using the title using its impact and
some of the visuals of gore incredible
but i do feel like it lacked some
butchering and it did lack some depth in
the top to make us compassionate enough
to land the second half black widow i
think if it came out in phase two or
phase three would be a top 15 marvel
film it is a jason bourne romp the
villain i liked as the main villain the
taskmaster villain didn't quite land for
me because the taskmaster choice of
having her get her powers by way of
digitizing things is completely contrary
to the essence of the character i don't
mind changing things from the comics but
when you change the essence that's an
issue i do think that we needed florence
pew i love david harbor a lot more works
than doesn't but someone has to be
second last last for me is i think dr
strange the multiverse of madness would
be an incredible what if my issue with
it is i love that we got a finally a
phase four where the directors get to
have their own time to shine the
directors should be able to play in
their world but unfortunately when
you've got so many movies leading into a
14-year sandbox when you sacrifice
character arcs like i think they did
with scarlet witch we've seen a
beautiful one through six arc of scarlet
witch then we got nine and ten i needed
to see seven and eight they literally
turned and she changed character the
beautiful thing about scarlet witch is
her nuance her empathy and they kind of
took that from my girl one of the best
acting performances in the mcu shouldn't
be undermined with a fade i love the
visuals i love the montages i love the
tone i loved the rainy but if this was a
what if incredible since it's in canon
mess me up
dusting act
okay
let's go baby you got this baby this one
had pretty colors
this one was fun too oh yeah no okay
spider-man no way home was fantastic
they did what all the spider-man movies
have been trying to do for a long time
which is make peter parker a broken new
yorker love it he's finally who he's the
essence of spider-man uh he's my
favorite superhero if i could be anyone
i would be spiderman shanxi was a lot of
fun uh similar did a fantastic job and
and my ranking is more so how much fun i
had in the theater or watching fun
these are supposed to be fun
entertaining comic book movies so i
liked the journey i liked that shanxi
went all over the world and into that
dreamy ethereal realm with his auntie
and the dragons and all that
very fun time dr strange multi uh
multiverse madness
really good time i love how sam raimi
got his uh claws in there we had zombie
doctor strange we had scarlet witch
doing her thing we had people getting
chopped in half by captain carter shield
fantastic although i didn't like how
captain the captain marvel of that
universe died just rocks falling on her
she's way more powerful than that she
flew through thanos this is chip that
was bs but other than that that was cool
throw up and thunder just saw it very
fantastic movie very fun i did enjoy it
a lot
uh it had to be on this half of the list
yeah
it's cool uh black widow very similarly
to you it should have come out like
eight years ago
um but it was a lot of fun david
harper's great florence p was great uh
the villain was a little confusing and
kind of like a throwaway villain i
thought uh love how she broke her nose
to get free and uh fuckboy oh boy up um
eternals
eternals a little too long uh too many
characters uh i i liked everybody in it
i love um uh tyree uh ron tyree henry
yes brian tyre henry and and uh angelina
jolie and everybody who was in it they
were great but i i yeah throw away and
also there's still a celestial halfway
out of the ocean and no one's talking
about it now we're about to find out
it's coming
it's already happening it's there no
scheduling nobody mentioned it here
nobody mentioned it here
he didn't mention anything nobody
mentioned it here
he originated so yeah that's why that's
at the bottom of the list but i'm
excited for phase four i've been having
a good time it's a great roller coaster
this is my ranking if you don't like it
too bad
perfect i'm gonna try and make mine
brief but i think we should also
acknowledge i noticed someone in the
chat i didn't like it said
uh it's too woke to put one character
here and i'm gonna acknowledge that the
mcu has been pretty white for a very
long time
and i'm finally happy that we're getting
diversity not even only in just color
and people that have like disabilities
of people that just are different people
there's the world's huge might as well
be inclusive that's why i'm starting
with shang chi sung shi was amazing i
think it was beautiful also you have a
man riding a dragon in jordan's you're
never going to see that again
dr strange multiverse madness for me was
really great just because i love sam
raimi this was a sam raimi evil dead for
the marvel cinematic universe i love
what they did for america chavez and i
really really love what they did for all
the different versions of doctor strange
and so i just want i i want to watch
this over and over and over again
because elizabeth olsen deserves her
dues and i will always ride for
elizabeth olsen thor love and thunder
made me cry which none of these movies
did thor love and thunder hit me
emotionally so i think driven wise this
is really great i didn't say that mine
realistically like for the marvel
cinematic universe is like this is what
the best ones are because clearly i
would like the rest of my fellow
companions put spider-man at the very
top but for me spider-man he
i yes it was really long in the making
and i think that was unfortunately one
of its demises that it took too long to
make and i think the character they
didn't make me feel for tobey maguire
because i haven't seen him since 2003
and for me i was uh
seven years old so
i'm sorry it it didn't pull too much for
me eternals is one of my favorite comic
books and to see how it was written was
kind of upsetting for me plus the cast
had a really hard time behind the stage
or behind the scenes so i didn't like
how they treated the cast behind the
scenes but i also just didn't like how
they treated um like athena or cersei uh
this one my favorite comic books i
didn't like it
i'm not gonna get into this
i don't even need to get into that
that's beautiful
so that is our phase four ranking by
experience
it's by your own experience everyone's
got opinions and one answer one always
has to be last because that's how lists
work we're not judging or negating
anyone's experience these films but i
want to know where do you all think this
is all heading i have every time i've
joined you guys in the show talked about
how i have theories about it being a
thunderbolt young avengers combo attack
how i think long game we're getting a
spiritual sequel to civil war by way of
kamala's law and i do think all of this
ties into very important things i also
think if you look at phase four halfway
into phase one there was not cohesion
until avengers the end of phase one if
you look at phase two things were
leading to age of ultron but they got to
be disparate parts phase three really
came together at civil war and that all
led to thanos but the post-credits
scenes were a large part of this all
unifying we're only halfway into phase
four it is a twice the length phase but
it doesn't make it any less uniting i
think we'll look back on this just like
we have at the other phases with the
weight of importance as it grows what do
you guys think and what um
i think with all of this being said i
think the series are my favorite uh the
movies were great but the disney i think
disney plus really nailed it home and
also i mean they do have much more time
to do that it's like a
an hour-long episode six episodes versus
like one movie that's two hours but i
just i think we should follow more
closely to what i know they probably
want us to follow the movies but more
closely to what disney plus is saying
than what the movies are saying so
i think we're kind of following this
more so
keep more eyes closer to disney plus i
think these are like uh you read comics
too annuals and event comics you know
like when you read like uh a secret wars
versus yeah the tie-ins
to me this feels like the event books
that are like okay this is something 100
seven issues but the shows are like your
your floppies like every week on
wednesday you pick up your books so i
agree with you yes i feel like they're
big uniting thing will be like some form
of
uh an incursion
because everything everything has like
dimensions now every show
every movie it's all about like oh
there's dimensions or there's realms or
like this is taking that i feel like the
big crossover is gonna be like all the
factors from like the ground to the
celestial like everyone like joining
together and be like look we all hate
each other but like we gotta sort this
out this universe is gonna take it let's
take them all out and then we'll deal
with our stuff and they planted that
seed as far back as dark world which we
were just talking about like incursions
in dark world that movie doesn't get you
know a lot of love someone has to be
last right but it does have some things
it's the first multiverse conversation
it's the first incursion event they've
been planting seeds for a while yeah
like everything now is like dimensions
and
gods universe like the gin and that they
did both gods and dementia recently it's
like okay there's a lot mm-hmm what are
you thinking i think it's heading
towards kang because of all these things
have like laid the groundwork and kang
had that
15 minute monologue at the end of loki
where he laid everything out and was
like you know this dimension this
multiverse you know this these things
all lead to this and so i think we're
getting big bad kang uh as our like big
phase four
baddie he's gonna be the new thanos um
and also this is for the general public
we need a bad guy like i don't think a
secret wars is
not to knock the public but simple
enough right for the kids to follow you
know
i do agree completely that the kang
moment the moment where he crosses over
that threshold is so important because
we've talked about kevin feige said
that's how the events of doctor strange
were able to happen was that moment so i
want to talk more about where we think
it's going in a minute but i know we
just crossed we do need to do something
this is important
aggressive
all right do the honors
take everyone take a viking squad where
a viking square take a square square
from square drawer this is this word is
i just got a lot of the consonants in a
row uh
black black queen
black queen which means black tooth
which i guess is like an insult like you
have a dead tooth oh
it's cool we got an old poop
don't smile at me with your black
black black twin
black black queen black queen
are you are you talking to me calling me
a black lion
um i got one that i i don't know if it's
really a swear i guess it could be um
oscillating which uh means born out of
wedlock use
arrows off a boat with that one
uh this one says
you have also none of else that's
definitely lq is a hard thing
i don't know what that is
it translates to fish belly so uh
get out of my way you stinky slimy
yeah yeah i told them yeah i sure did uh
mine's a lot of vowels i got i got sipil
s like sippy and then pillow yes like
simple uh and it means a pot licker so
uh that's a really tame insult
yeah what is in the pot you didn't do
the dishes you sipple yeah
yeah thank you for all those super
chatters out there uh john attend uh
new master 69 thank you
brianna johnson frey girl uh thank you
for all your super chats um we'll get
some of your questions at the end of the
show i think now before we wrap up phase
four a couple more things we want to go
over is do we think that with the
success of spider-man we have ended our
theoretical sony marvel
friendship they're homies but like
there's no longer paperwork do you think
i think they're coming back sony is
literally not not in
the meanest terms of a cockroach so i
said that i i couldn't think about it
that too that too but i think we're
constantly like finding a way to come
back um i from one of my friends i'm not
gonna say or that works at marvel
studios is constantly saying how it's
like they always have these limits for
sony and so he's like well we already
did it so it's like they're like oh you
have to work with us now because we've
already picked we already threw it out
here so it's like they they do that a
lot so i think sony's gonna be like no i
think they're gonna hold on to that
partnership sony especially because like
you know they tried morbius twice in the
theaters
like it's one of the biggest movies in
the history of movies they like having
the helping hand of marvel also and i
know i get crap about like you know how
much i love things but i think sony
really and this is they're not paying me
to say this they care so much about the
fan experience and i think they know
that they want the fan experience to be
tied into a universe that people love
yeah i think they know that people want
to see these certain things and so many
really invest in like how happy people
are at these things but uh the last bit
of thought is hulks we got she-hulk
coming and we've talked a lot about the
legal stuff like i know you love that
like flavor of kamala's law and the
civil war all those things you can do
and we've got doctor doom coming which
we've talked about and that means i
think as soon as black panther we get a
lot more of the government legislation
side along with all the gins and depths
and dimensions so i think we're going to
get kang and doom as kind of a one-two
punch i think doom might be phase five
we plant them phase four kang's are
phase four we build up to that but does
that mean we have hulk for secret wars
do we have shield do we have both
abominations in the trailer what do you
guys think oh yeah definitely both
because it looks like hulk will be in
the she-hulk disney show series yeah so
he's he's around being smart hulk yeah
that's the direction it seems like um
disney is taking the whole character uh
no no longer the big dumb hulk smash uh
version mark ruffalo came into after
taking it over from ed norton uh but
yeah i think we have both hulk and
she-hulk and uh you know jury's out on
red hulk yeah we'll see if that ever is
a thing that they try to do i i know we
lost uh the actor who played thunderbolt
but it'd be interesting to have someone
else another general or someone you know
get exposed to gamma radiation and like
have a full-on hulks film there's enough
characters and there's enough of a fan
base like we could have a captain
marvel's a hulks yeah i think that's
hulk works best with a team
by himself because it's either the story
he's in control or he's out of control
right yeah and either story is like has
limits and a lot of people have
complained with the mcu that hulk's
always been nerfed like he's never what
he is capable of but that's also like
what we
you have if you have that as a story
device it's kind of like well how do now
what do we do right you have this
unstoppable force like you have to find
a way to stop them and they do it all
the times in the comics constantly
getting stopped the team aspect you just
mentioned i think is why we lost the ed
norton take because obviously it didn't
do as well as the other mcu phase one
films but also they had norton hulk
sequel they were talking about with like
hulk on like a walkabout kind of like
they've done with thor right but that
doesn't allow the team dynamic and i do
think i love at norton's hulk but i
think mark ruffalo hulk is a team hulk
versus ed norton solo hulk
but i like like a hulk family movie
bring the kids yeah bring all the hotels
it'll be great
i mean i we all want like planet hulk
which they kind of did with i think they
did enough that i don't know if we're
going to get more planets i think secret
wars might be another gladiator hulk
though i think that way the planet hulk
fans that wanted more planet hulk they
might get another taste of like ready to
go and it's canon we've seen him be
ready for that
do we have hello fresh ads well yeah
speaking of tastes cause this guy's
the delicious taste of hellofresh
uh director john running in now to talk
about milwaukee
hello fresh is america's number one meal
kit and they're sending farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes right to your doorstep uh you
can choose from over 55 weekly options
so you can savor summer flavors right
from home
director producer john what are we
supposed to call you i don't even know
tell us about your hello fresh
experience eric and i are sharing a
microphone because we didn't plan this
well you're the very and the director so
that's right it's my fault um hi
everyone yes so uh we were short staffed
in the office last week so i got to
steal one of the hellofresh meals which
was a real highlight um i think we have
some footage of this if we can cut to it
so i made i made some delicious um look
at that cutting it was like a it was
like a tortilla beef special um and
honestly here's what i have to say about
this meal i didn't want to make it i was
very tired i was very very tired and i
had to make it for work and what i'll
say about that was it was so freaking
easy and as soon as i got going i like
put on some music i was vibing out it
was like such a delicious meal so much
better than whatever frozen crap i had
in the freezer oh um yeah i know the
best part about it was there was like a
good amount of leftovers pretty
delightful there's a good amount of
leftovers um that i could just snack on
for lunch the next day pretty good cold
um i am uh i live with two roommates but
we don't cook for each other i cook for
myself and so one of the best parts
about hellofresh is not having a bunch
of food kind of going to waste they give
you exactly what you need to make your
meal i didn't have to spend a bunch of
money at the grocery store buying you
know a whole container of shredded
cheese or you know what and then eating
it tonight yeah right a big packet of
tortillas that i wasn't going to get
through this was super easy super
convenient um it showed up to our office
but you could send it right to your door
you don't have to go out um hi jess
um so if you are interested in getting
hello fresh what would help us out on
the show is if you go to hellfresh.com
break room 16 and use code break room 16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts so uh zach also mentioned
yesterday on the show which i thought
was really cool if you're going on a
vacation with your family sometimes you
know you hit the grocery store on your
way up if you're driving and you buy a
bunch of stuff
you can actually send your hello fresh
uh to a template delivery and and just
have it there either either waiting for
you or
schedule it to show up
you know while you're a day or two in so
you don't have to do that like you know
like i grew up in northern california it
was always a pain in the ass to go to
like the expensive grocery store in lake
tahoe that up charges all the tourists
so send your hell fresh to your vacation
destination uh and and let hel fresh
know that we sent you what a flex
vacationing yeah that's right baby crazy
i like how you're you keep going at
people you're like you're flexing you're
flying you're yelling you travel
people are flexing you shop at target so
yes please go to hellofresh.com break
room 16 and use code break room 16 for
up to 16 free meals and three free gifts
that's code break room 16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts why is
it break room 16 uh because you get 16
free meals and three free gifts ooh
speaking of green like the hulk speaking
of green like the whole can you hear me
there no i have it over here oh you have
it over yet yeah i got it coming from
both athletic greens these are my babies
uh we also want to thank our friends at
athletic greens tommy beck told started
taking tommy beck told aka my husband
started taking ag-1 uh because he wanted
to get better gut health and more energy
and now he's been on it for two months
and he loves it with one delicious scoop
of 81 scoop it in there i'm going to i'm
also scrolling here i can help you okay
we don't we don't we like working solo
here um
with one delicious scoop of aging one
you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right the
scooper's probably in here why don't you
just pour a little bit in there like
it's kool-aid you just do i can eyeball
it
um this special blend of ingredients
support your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging
i'm looking at him because he keeps
telling me i'm too young
in aging right now it's time to reclaim
your health and your arm
and your arms and your arm no now it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements like philip takes to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you one free year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchases
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance watch me juggle it
oh this is open i can't juggle it
you'll ruin your morbid time shirt yeah
don't ruin zach's very expensive more
machine shirt uh as i shake up this
delicious ag one from my athletic greens
i gotta remind you folks it's time for
mandatory fun
yeah
here we go
ah man i really like mandatory fun so
much play it again
beautiful beautiful what do i do with
this just twice i'll set it wherever you
like uh one of my favorite things about
thor love and thunder was seeing the new
tourist industry that had sprung up
around new asgard well done king
valkyrie really doing well for the
business district uh and i myself am a
disgusting disney adult uh so i really
popped for this moment i love seeing a
theme park come to life uh so in the
vein of infinity scones the adora or
infinity cones the adorable ice cream
stand based around the annihilation of
half the life of the universe very dark
uh let's come up with some more
attractions for new asgard for this
mandatory fund now you get i don't
you're not allowed to just make up a
ride okay uh i want to spice things up
uh and like i said i'm a disgusting
disney adult with no children walking
around the park eating whatever i want
kicking kids in the face uh uh we're
gonna refurb some disney attractions
uh uh to fit in at new asgard okay so
you'll draw there's a couple restaurants
in here all right you'll draw it uh
think about it and pitch me how it's
going to fit into new ass cover you got
to keep the elements of the ride there
okay no just renaming do you want to do
the example yeah i'll give you an
example okay i'm a pro at this here we
go here we go
go ahead and dry some out so you can
think about it okay i got the plaza in
which is the restaurant lovely chicken
dinner you can generally serve at the
plaza and so this will be a sit-down
restaurant in new asgard this will be
called uh
this will be called uh
a valhalla
valhalla the valhalla experience okay uh
you'll have to get a reservation and
you'll be served a full viking meal at
the valhalla experience the valhalla inn
we'll call the valhalla that's too easy
uh you'll get a full viking meal with
the show uh all a cart and instead of
fried chicken uh it's fried goat sorry
sorry someone in the chat said chung chi
in the ten onion rings
from you but that was a great idea well
you can't because it's got to be
valhalla and new asgard oh that's true
they would be like
if tyler builds a theme park we actually
had this as a rogue theory question
before and it was when i taught i said
the thunderbolt toss salad
and everyone got mad at me yup it would
be shocking it would be shocking um i
got pinocchio's daring journey which i
assume is the ride where you go through
the yeah
i haven't gotten
so long or the line is so long so
pinocchio's daring journey clearly this
has got to be um
thor's daring journey and this takes
place it's already like okay it's like
10 years after what we just saw in love
and thunder right so you're on the ship
with the goats that are endlessly
screaming and you keep going through the
horizons you're going through the
universe but the ghosts are always
screaming it's a loop it's like small
world but instead of that horrible song
it's just these horrible goats screaming
and um it's fun it goes really fast and
you see some of the favorite characters
you see king valkyrie um you see uh you
at the very end it's the statue to jane
foster um even darcy lewis is there why
because we love her she's involved so
that's my
uh thor's daring journey beautiful
beautiful all right so i randomly
selected mr toad's wild ride oh good
ride i've never been on it i just went
to disneyland for the first time back in
like march what was great yeah good
times yeah you left there i know they're
so much beautiful i'm a disgusting
kicking kid
gotta get get them out of the way i'm
collecting pins get out of my way oh my
god so uh how to new asgard this up well
wild ride makes me think of the bifrost
so i would think this would become the
bifrost frolic where you're just
skipping along and getting drunk and the
floor is all rainbow colored or gnarly
and sometimes it it wobbles and then
there's like a conveyor belt in the
middle somewhere part of it and that's
also rainbow color so you can't always
distinguish it from the actual floor and
then you just slip and slide and fall
and just wild ride around okay bye frost
frolic mookie in the chat said loki poke
bowls and sushi
[Laughter]
love it so we got matterhorn bobsleds i
hate that
this one seems very simple to me because
we have in ragnarok thor getting
strapped to that chair and being
launched through tunnels and i feel like
i want the experience being strapped
into a bobsled and just being launched
into a place that i land with jeff
goldblum yeah i was like
the grand wizard and as you fly through
you see this no wait no not the great
different things
not just
they release their eyebrows
you experience the old asgard history
while you're like flying by and then
when you land you get to the final
destination which is you know the grand
master himself not wizard very important
i like that those were all great good
job we've been mandatory we did it we
got to keep going we have so much we
have dumbo's flying i'm not gonna i just
want to see the other rides it's just
like
it's just like you're there
doing the rock candy as guardians turkey
legs
also uh let the record show everyone
hates the turtles but i won the rank
very very marginally i don't deserve to
win the rankings
yeah as quick as i could i also want to
note that you couldn't see
mine at the very end it already started
voting
those are very close though they're very
close right yes
the live chat was angry at me for going
so long but i had i had passion i have
things to say very thorough i have
opinions
you gotta have that they love you they
love it
they love your asgard attraction is it
because of the thunderbolt tower salad
because
i think they added that on
it's a good season salad it just has a
lot of condiments good job
a lot of roughage in the toss yeah you
got to dig through a lot of garbage to
get there gosh the man is dead
oh oh yeah i'm sorry
i'm sorry spirit will live on in this
top salad you guys it's time for our
second discussion we're going to talk
about and i'm sorry if i'm coming off a
little sleepy it just hit just let me
tell you miss marvel has its finale
tonight now i don't know what i'm gonna
do uh the sadness of like any marvel
disney plus show ending even like kenobi
i was like what am i gonna do now what
am i gonna do now i know we were double
dipping on yeah for a couple weeks there
for a little while tuesday's rematch i'm
very excited for the finale it was nice
to see her in the the marvel logo during
thor she like pops up in the arm yeah
i was like oh a little part of the
family little girl made it i love it oh
that was me when i saw moon night i was
like
i literally went to the moon and went
come on
oh but tonight is the finale and a promo
promises to change everything
i think we got a clip to play real quick
i think i have this power for a reason
be the first
we're with you julian to witness the
finale we wouldn't want you getting into
any trouble that changes everything
i agree with someone in the chat that
says i truly just don't even know how
miss marvel is going to end i completely
agree i feel like there's so many open
ends to where it can go but our i think
one that i think is a common is are we
more likely to see cap are we gonna see
captain marvel is she finally gonna show
up at the very end i think um or anyone
else for that matter but i think a big
strong reasoning for her to show up at
the very end is every episode she's
getting getting pieces of her costume
and then she finally will get her name
and i think that will be the closer when
she finally meets her her idol and she's
like i am miss marvel so i think this
will be the like fully
me now she here's her outfit here she is
here she goes do you think she's going
to show up or you think someone else
what's more likely a captain marvel or
anyone else i mean they gotta have like
captain marvel show up on the show if
they don't do it what's the point well i
gotta do
that would be that would be my only
thing is that maybe it's monica but like
it's got to be kept
you got to do it
you got to do it
i think it's captain marvel i think that
setting up the show they figured out
those scheduling conflicts and like
whatever he had to do and i do it might
be a post-credits scene though it'd be
like a great credit because it might
literally be like the old phase two
where they shoot it and it's actually in
the next movie like this might be a
scene from the marvels so i think she
will show up but it might be post-cred
yeah i think it's monica rambo i think
full time spectrum or whatever name she
picks for herself in the mood uh we'll
come in and show now i i do think we
will get some embiggening from kamala
khan i think that'll be
like a big reveal or the like last blow
final
it'll be her it'll be her like
stretching yeah that'd be i think i
think that's i think that's what we're
going to uh someone says what about nick
fury some people have been saying nick
fury in the chat
i
he knows magic and i love magic i love a
man that can do close-up magic and i
love wonk um oh i do i want him to be
the new nick fury has portal will travel
he just bops around i love that guy i
think with nick fury showing up in this
i think uh we'll we'll see that in the
marvels more so than this is like i
think they're gonna i think we see uh
photon i think we see monica before we
see nick fury um i'm still holding out
for like my theory that photon and
captain marvel are gonna beef trying to
train kamala and then they're gonna
figure out that kamala doesn't really
need training she's really good as is
and she's going to bring them back
together because we know that there's
still a disdain between carol danvers
and monica rambo uh and i also think
carol killed her mom
this is a theory that is so deep that
i've been writing it's probably not true
but i will die on the hill uh well the
final battle be with the dodc or comrade
good question i don't think i think he's
good right now right
he don't think he's like
trying to use bruno
to get together
it did seem like they were like
did his mom take him over or just like
give him yeah we were talking about that
like is that corruption is it possession
like what level of her is in him i do
think there's influence i just don't
know if they're gonna go full on like
but the gin thing we haven't really
established it yeah i don't know i i
think the final battle will be against
tom run and he's like possessed by his
poem or something the dog i feel like is
a weird macguffin where it's like you
already did the like shields bad stuff
they're like making them making dodc bad
is weird oh they're definitely bad but i
think they're bad because government but
yeah yeah i think they're uh the big bad
overarching and i think that's gonna be
like maybe some scroll influence maybe
some like moments but i don't think
there's a big bad series i think there's
a big battle with like she-hulk kind of
setting up that she's working for the
dodgers which is gonna be interesting
wait again she hulk working for that oh
yes yes yes
i don't know i don't know i think she
finds out while working for them they're
not so great i think that's the reveal
in she-hulk because that she's defending
them she's our first superhero attorney
then she finds out they're actually like
knock-knock they'd be given too much
power i think the dod like uh koi said
the dsdc
is the villain you guys are the deal
they're not gonna give us that episode
where they're completely well that
episode made me so upset at how racist
they were being yeah
those guys get away with they're never
gonna be good but i think cameron's
gonna turn bad when he recognizes like
his mom died and no one stopped it which
you know it happens i love my mom
hey my mom is a good person
around stabbing people and expect
to live do we think that it's more
likely that bruno
what's more like now bruno john reading
the question out loud absolutely not
bruno is not going to get powers uh i
don't think bruno will get powers or but
more likely well more likely bruno or
the mom i assume this is what you're
talking about yeah what's more likely to
happen does bruno get powers or does the
mob get powers this is a world where one
of these things happens i think the mom
still has the ability to have the powers
i think it's in their family right but
bruno and the comics i loved his
storyline of him actually getting
injured by kamala and then going to
travel into wakanda to study and i think
that would still happen in the series if
there is a second season um we need to
recognize like she is she's amazing
she's great but she's also kind of
reckless with her powers so once that
power has actually hurt someone closer
that's what's gonna make her realize
that oh
my powers can be bad and we already saw
that established with the kid in episode
three or whatever i think his arm gets
hurt and this explodes
and i think that's i think that's an
awakening too is like how much trouble
he's been getting in just because kamala
is like he loves her and he's like i got
hit with a chair i'm getting killed by
villains i got exploded i got it i'm
going to mit or wherever kell arts or
whatever the caltech uh john said we can
go a little bit over for the discussion
just i know i noticed you were getting
trigger hips trigger happiness
on the controller uh is it more likely
that kamala will be revealed to be
inhuman kree or mutants slash enhanced
not mutants
definitely not mutants
i'd say inhuman if anything um
because there's there's been ties with
the the kind of light she emits right
kind of working as a sort of uh terrigen
mist in the series or as a placeholder
or like a a cousin to it so i think
that'll be the reveal that she isn't a
human and her you know asha and all the
uh ancestors
are in humans yeah i thought it was
really weird when they like touched the
the veil or whatever and they
kind of rocked up and then crumbled yeah
that reminded me of like terror jets
just like making that cocoon that's i'm
thinking it's definitely akin to it i
think it's i think it's a seed planting
that's kind of weird like everyone
thinks it's weird to throw out like
clandestines which was like a weird
small thing in marvel and then also this
gin thing and it's like what is all this
new stuff i think it's all misleads and
they just had like an inhuman in
multiverse of madness right so it's like
are they gonna make this real or not i
don't know is it possible that they're
just throwing a lot of things out there
so in four years they could be like oh
now we can actually put it down on paper
maybe almost guaranteed but it makes me
so mad that that's the case i think they
just were like i also feel like mislead
mislead misleading and then go back and
be like this one worked best
and i think that no i i'm not hating on
facebook at all but i do see that
happening a lot in facebook movies
recently where i'm like you guys gave us
like five different like outlets and
then i think it's only because in the
next movies you're gonna be like we can
choose one we can choose this one you
don't have to think about the other ones
and i'm like
okay are you lying to me or is this a
misdirect which one is it um are we more
likely to see a scroll or cree in the
finale
i would like to see a scroll well
agent cleary is definitely you think
he's a strong i think he's something
i think he's i mean if it is if they are
going to make her
a human then i think you've got to see a
cree yeah i think cree is i think both
are likely i think cree is like
mandatory like i think cree is necessary
to end the series but yeah but i think
because we're gonna sell creaking oh the
hand yeah so like i think we see a cree
to explain the other i think maybe
another bengal i think that's the word
yeah the second one yes i think we get
that in the last episode and i think
it's attached to a cree okay like a
whole whole ass creek he's like
his arms missing
why didn't it guy decompose decomposing
my bangle but you didn't get my hand
that'll be so funny um do we think
there's going to be any fun post-credit
fun cameos or setups
yeah do you think like the they'll
probably be a post credit right yeah do
you think it's going to be just like a
fun like
hi here's me or do you think it's going
to be like very important like really
set something up for either like
she-hulk i
i think which is like not at all the
anything factual i think that um in the
finale we're gonna get
uh more of the cree stuff more of the
comic book line or at least what i
thought of but i think the post credit
will be fun and it will like show that
one of her closer friends is also a soup
a superhero
different chef prince
i think they can i think they'll stray a
lot straight away from what was um
the timeline in the comics and the
timeline even here and add an additional
character that was not at all thought of
and i really would love it to be her
brother
he's so charming good acting
all right i want there to be captain
marvel at the end maybe post credit
maybe very end and then i think maybe a
she-hulk nod like a tease i think
she-hulk might get like cheat up do you
think it would be nice it does feel like
these shows have kind of been drifting
on their own island i would like to see
them i think eventually she-hulk defends
kamala yeah so i'd like to see her even
like even if they're not meeting like
just like setting up her show walk by
jennifer walter's ad i want who did i
want i wanted uh jennifer walters the
first represents someone else i want her
i just want her to go against i want to
represent zendaya like that courtroom
like that that whole thing she's like
defending peter like obviously we can't
now because the way they ended it but
like that dynamic i just hope we hear
blade off screen in the post-credits
scene and then like don't touch that
bangle
he's like i need that and he's with the
guy laid off screaming chest blade for a
while come on i'm ready to touch this
she's like cool
how did you get in my house
some of humans are always trying to ice
get
we ran some polls in the chat uh would
you like to see captain marvel a
prototype cameo 60 saying captain marvel
75 saying the final battle will be the
do dc
oh the government's bad we got to take
them down uh
is it more likely that kamala to be
revealed as an inhuman or
not uh 57 saying inhuman
that's fun uh and are we going to see a
skull or a cree or neither neither great
48
i think we're it's very strong on the
creek they're coming back on the crate i
just wanted to find a way to bring ronin
back i like ronin so much the accuser so
much fun yeah
pace had a good time taking the baths
putting on the makeup
i think i'm looking most forward to and
movies-wise uh the marvels and i just
need to see
i just need them to finally get into the
same room together do you see me at the
costa's candyman yes so incredible yeah
like i'm so much more excited about this
that's where you like
love for tiana paris yeah yeah and like
i also didn't like captain marvel's fine
but like yeah candy man's incredible
paris is amazing and she was so good as
monica but i just want them all all the
three women in the same room yeah
finally being like
look at us a family and then uh monica
be like nah don't touch me well also the
director of candy man's teaming up with
her again to direct marvel's too oh so
it's the director and her it's a combo
attack and that movie is so good yes oh
my god i love it uh but thank you guys
for tuning in today we're so excited for
the miss marvel finale this evening be
sure to catch you before we talk break
room tomorrow because i'm sure we'll be
uh breaking it all down uh tomorrow on
the show and thank you for all your
super chats today don't forget if we
raise a thousand dollars by the end of
the week we're shaving tommy from from
head to toe
uh it's going to be no
not head to toe it's going to be
beautiful if we do have a toe i call his
back i don't want to have a partner i
don't want it not filming that day not
here you want
thank you to all our super chatters
today uh jack of hearts jp quan elijah
bowser chrissy so many super chats uh
ver veray jsp clg comics thank you all
uh and thank you guys for tuning in uh
we'll see you here tomorrow on the break
room live right here same time same
channel same place
maybe same people who knows you have to
tune in and find out maybe same people
thank you so much we'll catch you
tomorrow goodbye